l'effet c'est que Louis Boyard c'est
c'est illustré par sa médiocrité ça
l'achetait son manque de loyauté et que
Cyril Hanouna réagi à la hauteur de sa
déception après je trouve que l'art
comme choix saisi bon bah on verra s'il
y a sanction mais je trouve que les
saisines sont un peu à géométrie
variable pourquoi dès que c'est 8
l'arcome est saisi on en parle beaucoup
et quid de France Inter donc moi
j'aimerais qu'il y a un traitement
égalitaire et que s'il y a une saisine
de l'arcome pour ses 8 il y en a une
pour les bobos France Inter merci Sarah
d'avoir été là tu étais avec
l'excellence et moi de Boudjellal et
dans les Grandes Gueules ce matin et
c'est vrai qu'on les avait posé cette
question de la recom doit-elle
sanctionner Luna et c'est vrai que tu
dis qu'il faut sanctionner tout le monde
toi ah non uniquement les bobos de
France Inter alors quand je dis France
Inter je vais quand même enlever les
assalames et je la mets quand même à
part pour moi c'est quelqu'un que je
respecte et que j'estime toi tu vas elle
y va direct
on va pas on va pas y passer par quatre
chemins moi il me faut des chroniques où
ils écrivent quand même Pascal Praud sur
youporn Sarah Salman donc je vais pas
non plus y aller par quatre chemins avec
tout le monde
c'est mes impôts c'est vos impôts qui
finançaient ce genre de conneries
c'est-à-dire que le groupe Bolloré c'est
de la c'est pas de l'argent public c'est
pas nos impôts et j'en ai aussi voilà
il y a pas de souci de sujet mais ce que
je veux dire c'est qu'avec nos impôts
toutes les personnes qui ne sont pas
dans l'idéologie dans la bien-pensance
de ces bobos déconnectés j'enlève le
Café de Flore parce que j'y vais ça je
ne suis pas d'accord
elle est venue elle nous a dit j'ai un
coup de gueule voilà sarah est
incroyable voilà donc les bobos de
France Inter regarde Sofia je te dis
comment ça s'est passé je pense qu'elle
s'est mis derrière son petit pupitre des
collier elle a pris son petit stylo elle
a dit alors comment je vais faire je
vais essayer de faire une vanne c'est
pas drôle mais elle était pas dans la
secte
Sofia Aram je vous je le redis elle a
fait deux jours sur Comédie quand j'y
étais et malheureusement c'est quoi
comédie comédie c'est la chaîne où j'ai
démarré où on était voilà et c'est vrai
que je n'ai plus jamais revu après et
c'est vrai que je pense qu'à la dans la
tête et que c'est une vengeance
personnelle après moi je vais vous dire
quand c'est drôle moi j'accepte toutes
les critiques là il y a une humoriste
France Inter qui a qui a fait une
chanson qui était nul et en plus
insultante ah oui mais c'est nul et je
vais te dire ce qui se passe en ce
moment c'est qu'il y a des pleins de
petits humoristes de France Inter de
tout ce groupe là qui essaie de se faire
connaître en essayant de faire des
parodies sur nous etc voilà donc je veux
dire moi ça me fait marier qui continue
France Inter franchement
c'est quand même
ils ont pas de pub sur France Inter donc
forcément ils font plus d'audience que
RTL voilà mais c'est si vous enleviez
les pubs sur RTL je pense que RTL soit
créé bien loin première radio de France
mais c'est vrai que ils ont pas de pub
donc j'aimerais finir en fait avec Sofia
mais elle a préparé sa chronique toi tu
étais on va dire dans la fête tu te fais
trahir par un ex amis elle elle prépare
donc il y a une préméditation elle est
pas dans le show elle a prémédité ça
punchline qui tombe à côté mais qui en
est une elle dit que tu que tu serais un
barbare et que les gens qui viennent
chez toi des invités donc moi en je
serai aussi une barbare mais pour qui se
prennent ces gens en fait c'est ça ma
question mais qui sont ces gens alors
qui font des des blagues à côté de la
plaque c'est pas des blagues avec mes
impôts mais déjà c'est pas drôle ils
sont pas drôles c'est ça le plus
important
alors je veux dire ils ont fait un truc
sur nous et franchement ils ont fait un
truc où ils ont expliqué voilà je t'ai
pas trouvé ça moi
il serait arrivé ça sur quotidien on
l'aurait traité aussi ils ont pas fait
un truc insultant ils ont fait un truc
voilà ils ont dit voilà il s'est passé
si ils ont passé ça foutu de ma gueule
là il y a 10 jours c'est marrant
alors moi vraiment car en fait j'ai vu
la fréquence en tant que
et
quand il dit un moment donné moi je
viens de la cité moi aussi et j'ai un
cité aussi et on nous apprend une chose
c'est être l'oreille et lui il y était
par quand on touche de l'argent de
ticket quelqu'un on ne va pas cracher
dessus
loyale on en sait quelque chose au GG
d'ailleurs nous enfin il les avait
plantés moi j'étais pas encore pour moi
la valeur principale c'est la loi iota
moi quelqu'un me donne l'heure dans 10
il y a par exemple un an je lui donne
une pendule dans 10 ans donc Louis
Boyard il a pas de leçon à donner à qui
que ce soit et je trouve que c'est
inadmissible c'est illustré par sa
médiocrité et puis il nous donne aussi
une mauvaise image de la gauche en fait
la gauche a peut-être déjà une mauvaise
image
c'est vrai oui Gilles moi ce qui me gêne
par rapport à France Inter quand même
c'est que c'est une radio de service
public qui mène une campagne organisée
orchestrée répétitive d'acharnement
contre quelqu'un c'est vous et ça ça me
dérange pas du tout non mais vous
exactement
ce que je voulais dire c'est ce que je
voulais dire c'est que quand vous avez
une campagne d'acharnement sans
possibilité de réponse du tout à un
moment ça doit être étudié voir
sanctionner il peut pas y avoir deux
points de mesure
exactement mais qu'ils agissent là-bas
aussi parce qu'il y a des propos
inacceptables tenus qui vous gênent pas
en tant que Cyril Hanouna
et les 2 millions et les 2 millions et
demi de gens qui nous écoutent sont
stigmatisés par ces propos insultants
donc effectivement que l'arcane fasse
son boulot pour tout le monde ils le
font alors Mourad Boudjellal était
également présent il a fait une
révélation il se souvient de la réaction
de Louis Boyard lorsqu'il avait été élu
à l'Assemblée il avait été déçu
l'excellent Morad regarde et j'étais
aussi que je connais aussi puisqu'il
était aux grandes gueules et je lui
avais dit sur ce plateau c'est super tu
es député et alors qu'est-ce que ça fait
ensemble ouais il nous a tu vas donc
confirmer les propos et il nous a dit
c'est super je pense que ça va me
permettre de rembourser mon crédit
étudiant et moi j'ai des très surprises
dit le mec il est élu député il nous dit
pas je vais essayer de faire ci je vais
essayer de changer ça c'est super je
vais pouvoir rembourser mon crédit ça
fait ça plus de 5000 € par mois c'est
bon il ne parlait que de son crédit
étudiant donc tu as l'impression qu'il
avait atteint son objectif de pouvoir
rembourser son crédit étudiant donc ça
c'est extrait il est incroyable
l'extrait de moi franchement ça c'est
fort ça c'est j'étais là quand il y a eu
cette séquence parce qu'en fait il y
avait le Off et avant de prendre
l'antenne moi je lui dis et j'ai été
Smart en plus il est la fille mais je
suis Smart j'ai dit voilà tu es élu
député à 22 ans c'est bien dit ouais
puis je vais avoir de l'argent là c'est
bon et avec Mourad on se regarde on fait
mais c'est ça c'est combat en fait c'est
ça c'est conviction et ensuite le ils
mettent le direct 3 2 1 et le direct est
là oui voilà donc je vais faire la
précarité étudiante voilà mes mesures
mais il y avait un offs et on en peut
plus de l'hypocrisie de ces médias comme
France Inter qui passe leur temps à dire
que vous n'êtes pas légitime à parler
d'information alors que ce gaffe sur
vous ils font des heures de progrès sur
vous si vous n'êtes pas intéressant qui
n'en parle pas et ces humoristes ne sont
pas des humoristes des juges en fait qui
sont là pour nous dire lui c'est une
bonne personne lui c'est une mauvaise
personne mais qui n'oublie pas une chose
tout le monde s'en fout de ce qu'il
pense en fait moi j'ai jamais vu une
chronique de Sophia Aram à part quand ça
parle de vous si jamais repris nous
partons
exactement
comme ça elle a lancé un nouveau
principe euh Sofia RAM le comique pas
drôle non mais c'est vrai c'est
incroyable non mais c'est vrai c'est
c'est un nouveau concept c'est
incroyable et si on pense intérêt ils
sont tous comme ça ils ont lancé un
nouveau truc c'est les comics pas drôles
c'est fou toi qu'un comique drôle c'est
vrai que tu seras jamais pris là-bas je
te le dis moi j'ai essayé non mais c'est
pas sur scène j'ai dit je vais essayer
de ne pas vous faire rire
je te jure ma mère est morte rire
tu es moche la guerre rire
c'est un principe sur France Inter voilà
il essaie de de ne pas être